welcome to exploring computing
today's video is creating web pages
forms get versus post
so if you've seen the forms videos we've
talked about how to create a form on a
web page and use it to
create some elements that allow the user
to enter information into the web page
and submit it to the web server
i mentioned that there are a number of
different attribute value pairs that can
go on the form
and one of them is the action the action
is going to determine what actually
happens
on the server when the user submits the
information and so typically this is
going to be the url
of the location of the program which
will respond when the user submits the
information in the form
so in this particular case i'm using a
relative reference
example.php and so this means that
there's a php program sitting on the
server and
the name of that php program is
example.php and it's located in the
exact same location as the html file
that has this form on here
if you're not actually working with a
program on the server
you actually do have some options so you
can use
a mailto url and if the user has
their web browser set up to interact
with their email system
this would actually email the
information in the form to you
stanford also has their own special set
ups that can get you
information from a form set to you
without actually doing any programming
on your own but
for now we're going to take a look at
what actually happens when uh
we're working with a form um and the
user is actually submitting information
to the server that's the most common
case
okay so that's the action but there's
also this method listed here and this
turns out to be
quite important it's important both uh
when you're actually
trying to set up a form for actual
interaction with a real web server it's
very important that you get this setting
right
it also has a number of implications uh
in terms of
when the users interact with the form
and i think
you'll discover when we talk about this
that you have run into these situations
before and maybe wonder
why the computer's doing certain things
in some cases with form and other things
in other cases with the format it turns
out that this setting has
some very visible effects to the user of
the web page
basically what the method controls is
how the information is sent to the web
server
this has important implications for
bookmarking and emailing web pages
so if you've ever tried to email a
friend
the results of a search and they weren't
able to actually get those results what
was going on was
the post versus get here
and it also has implications in terms of
whether or not the
state of the server is changed by the
submission of the form so let's go ahead
and take a look at this first part here
how the information is being sent to the
server and the side effect on
bookmarking or email in the webpage
url okay so here is an actual form on
amazon.com
and i've taken out part of the uh the
form tag here
uh so here's the actual action and the
method is actually get
if we look down at the bottom you can
see the url that is generated when
somebody clicks on the submit button
here or the the little extra the little
search icon on the far right of the
search bar there
and we can see that the action there
slash s slash
ref equals nb underscore sb underscore
nos that's our relative reference and
uh if you look at the actual url at the
bottom of this uh
image here you can see that that gets
tacked onto www.amazon.com which is what
you'd expect with a relative reference
so it's saying
hey when somebody clicks on the little
search icon here to submit the form
information
go ahead and go to this particular
location
as specified by the action on
the amazon.com server
but if you look past the the
nb underscore sb underscore nos you'll
see that there's some additional
information here
and that additional information is
actually
determined by the the selection of the
user on that select tag and whatever the
user has entered into the text field
and so uh the first thing we have here
is the url equals search
alias and so it turns out that that
electronics um that we're looking at
there that's actually part of a select
tag
and the name of the select tag is url
and
as you may recall from the forms video
when information is sent
from the uh
web browser to the server uh and we've
got a bunch of elements on our web page
it's sent in the form of
name of element followed by value of uh
the element current value of the element
so in this particular case
the name of the element is url and the
search dash alias equals electronics
is the value of the option the
electronics option that the user has
selected here so
what's happening here is this
information on the user's current
selection
is being sent to the web server and it's
being set
by attaching it to the url itself and if
you're wondering what that percent
3d is that's actually an encoding for
that equal sign there
you know i mentioned before that you
want to be really careful
in terms of what sort of punctuation you
put
inside of your your file names and
as i've recommended before i recommend
you stick to lowercase
letters digits 0 through 9
and dashes things like spaces or in this
case the equal sign
can't get transmitted but it does get
converted using this
url encoding so in this particular case
3d
is the hexadecimal
encoding for an ascii equal sign and so
you get a percent 3d set
uh in place of the actual equal sign
when this goes to the server
and then the text field there where i've
typed in ipad
the name of that text field is field
keywords
and then of course the value that i've
typed in there is ipen so you can see at
the end of the url
it indicates that i've i am submitting
this information to the server
using uh with the value for field
keywords of equal
ipad and so the basic idea here is
the url here includes
the information that i've entered into
the form and so there's there's a number
of implications of this
if i were to bookmark this webpage
what's going to get bookmarked
is this url and this url includes the
information i entered into the form so
if i go ahead and bookmark this webpage
and then i go back to that bookmark
in a day or two i'm going to get the
results of the original search it's
going to know that i was searching
in the electronics section of amazon and
that i was looking for an ipad
similarly if i were to email this url to
a friend
and they were to click on the link and
in their uh email system
it would include the information from
the form that i entered so they're going
to see the exact same results as if they
had entered this information into this
form
now let's say we go ahead and change the
method on
the form here from get to post
and i i do want to emphasize that amazon
uses get here
but if you were to go ahead and switch
this to post we're going to get some
different results here
what happens with post is the
information is sent to the web server in
a different form it's not included in
the url
it's actually stored internally in the
http request and it's not directly
visible just by looking at the url
and so the url with the post request
here
and i do again want to emphasize that
this is a change i have made this is not
actually what occurs on the amazon
website the amazon website uses get
but if we were to use this post request
notice that the url here down at the
bottom of the page does not
include any indication that i'm
searching in the electronic section or
that i enter the ipad
as the keyword that i'm searching for
instead it just has
the the action there tucked on to the
end of the server name
and there's no additional information on
the url
so the implication here is if i were to
go ahead and bookmark this particular
web page
and i would go back to that bookmark it
wouldn't know
that i was looking in the electronics
section and wouldn't know i was looking
for an ipad
all it would know is that i had
submitted a search request to amazon but
it would have
no information on what that search was
and so i would not see the results of
that search
and so if i use
a post request instead of a get request
in my form and somebody tries to
bookmark the results
they're not going to be able to bookmark
the results
similarly if i go ahead and take this
url here
and i email it to a friend instead of
them seeing the results of my looking
for an ipad in the electronics section
they're just going to uh see some
indication that uh
you know i had performed a search on
amazon or they might even get an error
message from amazon saying
hey i see you're trying to do search but
i don't understand what you're trying to
search for
and that's because with both the
bookmarking and when we take the url we
email it to people
the only information being stored by the
web browser for the bookmark is the url
and of course the only information that
our friend gets is
the url i've emailed them so when the
information is encoded
into the url with the get request that's
great
and people can see exactly what i was
looking for and the information i
entered into the form
but if we're using the post request that
information is not included in the url
and so
we don't get any of the results
the url does not include any of the
information about what i entered in the
form
it only knows that i tried to enter some
information but not not actually what
was associated with it
okay so let's go back to our summary
here
so we've seen that get versus post
controls how the information is sent to
the server
either the information is encoded into
the url or it's
uh enclosed within these
the actual http request and it's not
included as part of the url and as a
consequence
i can bookmark or email urls
using the get requests and people will
get the actual results as i expect
whereas if the form is submitted using a
post request
that information is not included in the
url and so
it's lost um there's a second
implication of get versus post and
arguably this is
more important but it's something that's
not normally seen by
by users but it's very important for
getting right in terms of if you're
actually setting up your server
and your web pages and that is
setting get versus post to terms of
whether or not the state of the server
may be changed
so get requests are what we refer to as
item potent
and what item potent means is they do
not change the state of the server
and so the idea here is if i make a get
request
and i make another get request you know
an hour or two later
that the get request should get the
exact same results so
if i go ahead and make a get request on
amazon looking for ipads and then i make
another
request 15 minutes later i should get
the same results that's the implication
of using a get request
and in fact the web browser is welcome
to cache the results in the browser
cache
which means it's going to store the http
um and any associated files like css
files or image files
um from the original request and it's
able to look at that
and you know there may be some sort of
expiration date on that
but it's able to look at that and say oh
you made this request
15 minutes ago i still have the results
from the last request they haven't
expired yet so i'm just going to go
ahead and display
the previous request
post requests and contrast are not item
potent this means they can change the
state of the server
so let's take a look at some usage
scenarios of forms
and whether or not we would want the
result to be item potent or not
so suppose i look up a word on in
dictionary or on wikipedia
do i expect the results to change well
hopefully not i mean dictionaries do
change language does change but it
doesn't change very frequently so
you know if i make a request to
dictionary.com looking at particular
word and then i make a request
12 hours later i should get the exact
same results there should be no change
at the state of the server and certainly
my request is not changing the state of
the server
so this is an important point
it's not that the state of the server
can't be changed it's that
my submission here is not changing the
state of the server
so you know maybe at the end of the year
dictionary.com decides hey
this word is being used in different
ways so they go ahead and change
their information on the server but it's
not like i am submitting new information
that's changing the state of the server
similarly for wikipedia assuming i'm
doing a lookup
uh you know that's going to be item
potent
you know if i look up information about
stanford university and i look up that
information a little bit later
the results should be the same now if i
were to
be a wikipedia editor and i would
actually modify that web page
well that's a different request and so
the id the way this would work is that
when i'm looking up information on
wikipedia that needs to be get requests
when i'm changing the information on
wikipedia
that actually needs to be a post request
because it is making a change on the
server
let's say i order something from amazon
that needs to be a post request because
i'm changing the state of the server the
server's database is being modified to
include information about this new order
that has come in
so if i put in a get request instead of
a post request
that will cause problems similarly if
i'm posting something on an electronic
bulletin board
i expect other people to see it that
means there needs to be a change
on the server in order for people to see
what i posted there same thing if you're
posting on twitter or facebook or
anything like that
okay one thing that you may notice with
post requests is
uh if you reload a web page which has a
post request
you may get this uh this dialog box
saying
hey do you want to resubmit this
information this is happening because
the post requests are
changing the state of the server or at
least potentially changing the state of
the server
and so you know if i uh
order an ipad at amazon and then
i reload the web page what it's saying
is hey the first time you
uh clicked on that link you ordered a
new ipad from amazon
um you're trying to reload the webpage
should i tell amazon you want to
order a second ipad and so this is
in contrast with what happens with a get
request for the get request i'm just
getting information from the server
there's no change in the server status
and so if i reload a web page with a get
request
the web browser is like that's all good
i can get you the same results and in
fact i may have the results sitting in
the cache
so when you see that do you want to
resubmit
and you you know you may notice that
sometimes you get that do you want to
resubmit
dialogue and sometimes you don't and you
may be wondering what the difference is
well the difference is that
that form is either marked with method
equals get or method equals post and
depending upon
which of that settings is being used you
will either
the web browser will either be like it's
all good i can just redisplay the
results
or it's saying hey this actually changes
the state of the server
we already did that once do you want me
to change the state of the server again
and so that's what's going on there
now it is important that you use the
proper
method type for the proper usage um
using a get request when you're you
actually want to use a post request
will cause problems uh if the result of
a get request is still in the web
browser cache as we mentioned before a
second get request may not be received
by the web
server and so the idea here is uh
if you actually want the state of the
server to be changed
you need to use the post request if
somebody ordered something from my
online store
and we use a get request i can
ignore the fact that the get request is
supposed to be idempotent and i can go
ahead and grab
that information on the server and i can
update my order database
but if they were to do a second
get request to order a second version of
that item
the web browser would be completely
acting appropriately if it were to say
hey
you already made this get
request yesterday i still have the
results in the web browser cache
as far as i can tell it's still valid
i'm just going to redisplay that i'm not
even going to bother contacting the
server to tell the server that
you know you're you're resubmitting this
get request because
the meaning of a get request is i'm only
returning information i'm not actually
changing anything on the server so
you know if you want to or need to have
the information on the server changed
make sure you use a post method
on your form and not the get method on
your form
okay so conclusions use a get request
when you can it's much more convenient
for the user to
uh to have that information there in the
url uh
and to be able to bookmark it and email
to people and things like that
um use a post request when you must so
if the submission of the form needs to
change
something on the state of the server uh
you definitely do not want that to
uh to happen with a get request because
as we saw that can cause problems
alright so that's it for forms i'll talk
to you all soon